My name is Jeremy Stickney
I'm 21 years old, I live in Toronto. I went to Evans three-day workshop...
and from there, I just started my own YouTube channel. I'm also an investor...
[ Q&A time. HOW CAN I HELP? WHAT HAVE YOU GOT? ]
I'm just pumping out content, [ YEAH ] a lot now on YouTube but...
the views aren't coming in which is normal, of course...
[ OKAY ], and I hear a lot of people talking about running like stuff like Facebook ads [ OKAY ]
or promoting videos through ads and stuff, like is that a practical...?
Should I be spending money at this early in the game [ NO ]to just rank it?
No, yeah. [ THE ONLY REASON TO RUN ADDS... ]
[ IS IF YOU NEED THE VANITY METRICS FOR SOMETHING... ]
Mm-hmm. [ IT BASICALLY MAKES YOU LOOK BIGGER THAN YOU ARE AND THAT HELPS YOU IN SOME RESPECT... ]
[ TO HELP YOU CLOSE A DEAL OR SOMETHING THEN YOU CAN BUT... ]
[ PAID ADS VERY RARELY CONVERT TO SUBSCRIBERS, YOU SPEND A LOT TO GET... ]
[ SUBSCRIBERS ]. Mm-hmm. [ SO YOU'LL GET LOTS OF VIEWS... ]
[ BUT YOU WON'T GET ANY ENGAGEMENT AND YOU WON'T GET ANY NEW SUBS FROM IT... ]
[ IF YOU HAVE MONEY... ]
[ THAT YOU'RE SPENDING, I WOULD SPEND IT ON, HOW DO I GET BETTER WITH MY CONTENT?... ]
[ AND IF YOU'RE DOING THOUGHT LEADERSHIP STUFF LIKE IF IT'S YOU TALKING TO THE CAMERA... ]
[ TALKING HEAD STUFF LIKE WHAT I DO... ]
[ THEN IT'S...THEN IT'S YOU... ]
[ LIKE YOU'VE GOT A FANCY CAMERA, IT'S RECORDING HERE TOO... ]
[ HE'S GOT THIS SONY FANCY CAMERA WITH MICROPHONE... ]
[ LIKE THAT'S ENOUGH, THAT'S MORE THAN I HAD... ]
[ YOU'VE GOT A NICE... YOU'VE GOT A NICER TRIPOD THAN ME... ]
[ A NICER CAMERA THAN ME... ]
[ THE VARIABLE IS GONNA BE YOU... ] mmm-hum            [ HOW GOOD ARE YOU?... ]
[ HOW GOOD ARE YOU ON CAMERA?,                           HOW GOOD ARE YOUR IDEAS?... ]
[ HOW GOOD ARE YOU AT SWIMMING...AND THE PEOPLE LIKE IT... ]
[ IF PEOPLE LIKE YOUR CONTENT...                                 IT'S NEVER BEEN EASIER TO SHARE... ]
yeah
[ IF PEOPLE LOVE THIS, THEY CAN SHARE IT... ]           mmm-hum...
[ IF THEY THINK IT'S GARBAGE THEY WON'T... ]          yeah, well, yeah sure...
[ AND IT WAS JUST OKAY THAT THEY WON'T EITHER...]
[ LIKE YEAH OKAY... ]
[ I LEARNED SOMETHING AWESOME BUT NAAAH I'M NOT GONNA SHOW MY FRIEND THAT... ]
yeah [ SO, IT'S GETTING THE CONTENT GOOD ENOUGH...AND... ]
[ THAT'S THAT SUCKS... AND IT'S THE BEST... ]
mmm-hum
[ IT SUCKS BECAUSE, LIKE MAN... ]
[ IT MEANS YOU SUCK, RIGHT?... ] yeah
[ YOU 'VE GOTTA GET BETTER BUT... ]
[ THE GOOD PART THIS IS ALL UNDER YOUR CONTROL... ]
[ LIKE YOU'RE NOT LIMITED BY HOW MUCH YOU CAN SPEND ON AN ADD ON FACEBOOK OR ON YOUTUBE... ]
[ SO IT'S GOOD, IT'S JUST... ]
[ IT'S AN ADVANTAGE FOR YOU BECAUSE YOU WORK HARD... ]
Mm-hmm.
[ AND SO IF YOU, IF EVERYDAY, KEEP, KEEP PRACTICING PRACTICING PRACTICING PRACTICING... ]
[ GETTING BETTER AT THE CRAFT... ]
[ SO THAT... ]
[ SOME PEOPLE RECOGNIZE IT, AND WHAT YOU'LL FIND IS THAT YOU MAY HAVE A VIDEO TOO... ]
[ THAT BLOWS UP FOR WHATEVER REASON, BUT IT'S MORE... ]
[ YOU JUST START HITTING MORE PEOPLE... ]
[ SO ON MY YOUTUBE CHANNEL... ]
[ I DON'T KNOW HOW FAR BACK LIKE WHEN YOU... WHEN YOU FIRST FOUND ME... ]
[ AND WHAT I WAS DOING BUT... ]
a couple of years ago...
[ SO... ]
[ THERE'S BEEN SOME PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN LIKE OG'S, LIKE RIGHT FROM... ]
[ NOT QUITE THE BEGINNING, BUT CLOSE... ]
[ SO WE'RE STILL STICKING AROUND, AND THEY'VE SEEN THE TRANSFORMATION... ]
[ AND... ]
[ FOR ME 'CAUSE MY CONTENT, I WASN'T VERY GOOD ON  CAMERA... ]
[ I DON'T..., THAT MUCH OF WHAT I SAID OR OPINIONS HAVE CHANGED THAT MUCH... ]
[ I'VE JUST GOTTEN BETTER AT EXPLAINING THEM, AND BETTER ENERGY AND... ]
[ MORE EMOTIONAL COMMITMENT... ]
[ I HAD PEOPLE IN EARLY DAYS AND THEY LOVED WHAT I MADE... ] mm-hmm
[ THE BETTER I GET THE MORE I CAN WIDEN THE FUNNEL... ]
Yeah [ SO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE LISTENING TO YOU RIGHT NOW AND SAY WOW THAT'S REALLY HELPFUL... ]
[ IT'S A TINY LITTLE PERCENTAGE... ] mm-hmm
[ AND THEN YOUR GOAL IS JUST INCREASE THAT BY HALF OF PERCENT... YOU KNOW... ] each time...
[ EVERY MONTH, YOU KNOW... ] yeah
[ I'M SLOWLY HITTING MORE PEOPLE ALRIGHT, I'M SLOWLY GETTING BETTER... ] yeah
[ IT'S NOT THAT ACTUALLY SUCKS... ]
[ IT JUST CAN ONLY HIT A COUPLE PEOPLE 'CAUSE IT'S NOT... ]
[ YOU'RE NOT GOOD ENOUGH YET... ]
[ I DESERVE TO BE WHERE I'M AT BUT I DON'T DESERVE TO HAVE 10 MILLION SUBSCRIBERS... ]
[ I DON'T DESERVE TO SELL OUT ARENAS... ]
yeah...
[ 'CAUSE I HIT 'X' PERCENT OF PEOPLE... ]
[ WHICH IS BETTER THAN I DID BEFORE, BUT IT...BUT I WON'T HIT AS MANY PEOPLE AS TONY ROBBINS WILL...] mm-hmm
[ 'CAUSE HE'S BETTER AT THE CRAFT THAN I AM... ]
[ AND THAT'S AWESOME... ]
[ I UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION IS ALWAYS LOOKING FOR WAYS LIKE... ]
[ HOW ARE WE HACKING THIS?, HOW TO GET BETTER... ]
[ AND I FEEL THE SAME THING AND I'M ALWAYS HACKING... ]
[ AND THESE THINGS THAT YOU CAN DO... ]
[ TO HACK AS WELL... ]
[ IF YOU LOOK AT ON YOUTUBE... ]
[ ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE ANY OPINIONS ON CURRENT TRENDS THAT'S HAPPENING... ]
[ SO I'M THE WEAKEST AT THIS... ]
[ 'CAUSE I DON'T FOLLOW THE NEWS... ]
[ I DON'T PAY ATTENTION TO TRENDS AND TO WHAT'S HAPPENING... ]
[ I KNOW I'M IGNORANT IN MOST THINGS... ]
[ I KNOW A LOT ABOUT LIKE FOUR THINGS AND NOTHING BUT EVERYTHING ELSE... ]
I get that, yeah...
[ THAT'S A STRENGTH AND WEAKNESS... ]
[ BUT WHATEVER HAPPENED TODAY ELON MUSK SAID WHATEVER... ]
[TALK ABOUT IT... ] video on it...
[ GIVE YOUR POINT OF VIEW... ]
[ IF YOU WANT TO BE A THOUGHT LEADER THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO... ]
[ IS GIVE A PERSPECTIVE THAT PEOPLE DIDN'T THINK OF IT BEFORE... ]
[ SO SHIFTS THEIR THINKING... ] yeah...
Also... if you want to know what I think...
and what other successful entrepreneurs think about building confidence...
check out my new - 254 CONFIDENCE SERIES -...
where everyday for the next 254 days for free...
I will send you a 30-second to 5-minute video in the morning...
to help you build unstoppable confidence...
the link is in the description below...
If you want to be more confident you need to surround yourself with things that make you feel... confident...
Realizing that any big endeavour is the collection of a lot of small stuffs that came before...
If you're doing work that you love...
you're more likely to follow through, you're more likely to do it...
because it doesn't feel like work, because you love doing it...
BUT LET ME GIVE YOU THE ONE WORD SECRET TO HAPPINESS...
ONE WORD THAT'S ALL YOU NEED TO BE HAPPY...
It's the most important word we ever...
IF YOU HAVE TO THINK OF... ONE WORD THAT'S MOST IMPORTANT TO YOU...
OR THAT SOUNDS YOU UP OR...THAT WOULD BE KIND OF LIKE A LITTLE BEACON...
If you want to learn 7 of the fastest ways to grow a Youtube channel...
check out the link right there next to me...
I think you'll enjoy it...
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE... AND I'LL SEE YOU THERE...
So today I'm going to share with you with the help of my friend...
the 7 different ways that quickly grow your YouTube channel...